and here's the thing I didn't know I
don't know if you guys did that um
obviously you were obi-wan Kenobi but
Yuri don't know that no I doubt it but
that you're in the new one you're in the
new store well hardly I mean I my voice
is in it for a second
I recorded a little line in it something
but when do you speak I took care I
don't know
have you seen it did but I guess I
thought it was very good that line
excellent that bit where that's a I
don't remember if where I speak no idea
but very Alec Guinness speaks in it as
well yes I think the beginning of the
line is the character's name is Ray I'm
really struggling yet so I think the
character's name is of course you all
know ray it is I'm damn sure I wanted a
line of dialogue that said ray
there's some other line that I say yeah
and brave easier first steps or
something what ray these are your first
steps or something something that's what
he said something something anything
these are your first steps or something
so they recorded me saying it and then
they took they phoned Alec Guinness sing
afraid and they cut the a and they are a
a d often and they took the Ray
so it's Alec Guinness sing ray and then
me saying that other line that you said
yeah did you have to go all the way to
Tunisia to do that or did you know who
you had was obviously a very last-minute
thing I mean JJ Abrams emailed me out of
the blood and he got my email address
from someone and emailed me but it was
about two weeks before the film was
released so it was old man all of a sort
of last minute oh oh yeah less that
might be good idea
Oh funny it was like subscribe to be
part of it was nice
a present to go with these wolves they
weren't time but they were socialized
and there were no that means they just
don't kill you I'm selling sort of
toiletry products as a rep up and down
the country but you never gave up the
dream of being a pop star